- [Narrator] Bitcoin's meteoric rise
is attracting a ton of attention,
but is it ready for the mainstream?
JPMorgan Chase CEO Jamie
Dimon recently called Bitcoin
a fraud and said that
cryptocurrency prices
are in a bubble that
will eventually burst.
Many investors have
stayed on the sidelines
as cryptocurrencies are
seen as too volatile
and don't have the safeguards
that most financial assets do.
A number of hedge funds,
however, are investing
in cryptocurrencies, and
Goldman Sachs is reportedly
exploring how it can help
clients trade digital tokens.
Other companies are stepping up efforts
to bring cryptocurrency to the mainstream,
opening regulated exchanges,
creating futures contracts
and attempting to list
exchange traded funds.
The recent surge in cryptocurrency prices
has coincided with a flood of interest
about the blockchain
technology behind Bitcoin,
which uses a decentralized
and public ledger
of transactions that can't be manipulated.
IBM, Microsoft and Toyota have
all invested in blockchain
and are looking at potential applications
ranging from food safety
to driverless cars.
So what is preventing even
more widespread adoption?
Regulation, or the lack thereof.
In July 2017, the SEC announced
that federal securities law
may apply to some cryptocurrencies,
without providing concrete guidelines
to determine which ones.
Meanwhile, China has outright banned ICOs,
or Initial Coin Offerings,
along with the exchanges
where coins are traded.
Guidelines for individuals
that mine and trade
cryptocurrencies also vary wildly,
with countries like Venezuela going as far
as putting miners in jail.
So what's next in the year ahead?
The cryptocurrency community
is eager for clarity
from regulators on ICOs,
trading, mining and taxes.
As that happens, more
investors and end users
could dip their toes in the water.
Many have compared the
current state of blockchain
to the early days of the internet,
a digital wild west
teeming with opportunity
and just like the internet,
there will likely be winners and losers.